How much do you know about black holes?
What would happen if you fell into one?
Say One day you were exploring space,
looking for a new planet for humans to inhabit,
but came across a black hole and decided to check it out?
Would you have any chance of survival?
How would you get out?
Would there be a short cut to another universe?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if you fell into a black hole.
Despite being black and a hole.
A black hole is not a dark,
empty space.
In his theory of relativity,
Einstein predicted how black holes are formed.
When a massive star dies,
it leaves a smaller remnant core behind.
If the core mass is at least three times bigger than the mass of our sun,
gravity overwhelms all other forces and turns the core into a black hole.
But don't let its name for you.
A black hole isn't a hole at all,
but rather a huge amount of matter packed into it.
Very small space.
Think of the Sun with its gravitational field 28 times stronger than Earth's.
If you were to walk on the son,
you'd be 28 times heavier than you are on earth.
Now imagine squeezing four sons into something that's just 15 miles in diameter.
The distance you can cover in a 30 minute drive,
what would the gravity be like?
They're a black holes.
Gravity is so strong that even light can't get out.
That's why you'll never see one,
but you can detect it from the gamma rays bursts that the whole limits these
bursts discovered by Stephen Hawking.
Now carry his name,
hawking radiation.
Stephen Hawking himself believe that black holes can be passages to another
universe.
So if you were to fall into one,
would you find yourself in an alternate dimension?
Every black hole has an event horizon.
The point at which gravitational pull becomes so strong,
you can't escape from it.
The point of no return.
If you found yourself outside of that point,
you'd see that stars are twisted around a perfect circle of darkness.
As you start being pulled toward a black hole,
you'd be moving faster and faster.
Accelerated by the force of gravity.
That's the first bad news for you.
Brave space traveler.
The gravitational force of a black hole is very good,
very strong.
If you fell feet first,
your legs would be feeling a stronger gravitational pull,
then your head,
your body would be stretched apart.
The most common black holes are called stellar.
They can stretch about nine miles across and be as heavy as 20 sons.
If you happen to be pulled towards a stellar black hole,
you'd be completely torn apart before you even reached the event horizon.
So make sure to choose a supermassive one,
the one that's a million times heavier than our sun.
In this case,
your body would remain unharmed as you cross the event horizon as the gravity
wouldn't be pulling both your feet and your head with almost the same strength.
And if you're wondering where to find one,
you don't have to look too far.
There's one right at the center of our Milky Way galaxy of luckily it's 165
quadrillion miles away from us and we'll suck in neither of the sun nor the
planets,
but don't pack your suitcase just yet.
Crossing the event horizon is just the beginning of the challenge.
There's a gravitational singularity at the center of the black hole where
density becomes infinite.
You'd be squashed into that center and become one with the black hole.
You wouldn't be able to tell anyone about your experience.
However,
a person observing you from outside the event horizon,
we'll see a very different picture as you were falling into a black hole.
They'd see you slowing down,
getting dimmer and redder.
In the end,
you just freeze,
never crossing the event horizon.
This is because space and time in a black hole swap the roles at the event
horizon.
Time comes to a standstill.
While space on the other hand moves forward.
You wouldn't be able to turn around and escape the black hole any more than you
could travel back in time.
Even when the black hole eventually died,
emitting all the particles it had absorbed including your body,
it would be impossible to tell whether those particles where you Stephen
Hawking,
however,
found a way in which the information about your body wouldn't be lost.
He theorized that there are alternative universes with different histories.
This means in one reality,
you fell into a black hole.
In the second one,
there was no black hole.
It's impossible to be certain from outside of the event horizon,
whether there's a black hole or not until you fall in there.
If you cross the event horizon and there was a black hole CNR,
but if you happen to be in a reality where the black hole didn't exist,
you'd still be alive just in a different universe.
There would be no way for you to get back to ours.
Would you dare explore the possibility?
Are you drawn to black holes in the universe?
Very soon.
We'll take you on your next hypothetical adventure.